Sometimes students have a hard time determining whether something is
reinforcement or punishment, or positive reinforcement or negative
reinforcement. The first the easiest thing to do is to say does the behavior
increase? If the behavior increases, it's reinforcement. If the behavior
decreases, it's punishment. After you decide that, then go back and look, did
the behavior increase because something was added to the environment? If so
that's positive reinforcement. Or did the behavior increase because something
was taken away from the environment? If so that's negative reinforcement. And
the same for punishment. If behavior decreases, did it decrease because
something was added to the environment, for example a painful shock? That would
be positive punishment, and removing something from the environment and
behavior decreasing would be negative punishment. So first ask, does behavior
increase or decrease? And then ask, did it happen because something was added
to the environment or taken away? You can use this when you're going through
the problem sets, but I encourage you to look at your own life and see examples
of positive and negative punishment, and positive and negative reinforcement.